こんにちは3億円の豪邸の持ち主はじめ
しゃちょーです
今日も3億円の豪邸が美しいはい皆さん
毎度おなじみになっておりますはじめしゃ
ちょーの家佐野県の豪邸でございますもう
積んでみて1年ぐらい経ってるんです
けれどもなかなか改造したり中の照明を
変えたりして日々アップデートをし続け
てるわけです私の家昔は暗かった玄関も今
やこんなに明るいルカリオあんなに家の
外装の話したことないんですけども俺特に
気に入ってるのがこのコンクリートの壁と
か外壁のこの感じとかめっちゃ好きなん
ですよそうかっこいいんですよこれねこの
コンクリートの感じがマジでかっこよくて
一番押され
[音楽]
ちょいちょいちょいちょいちょい案内する
だけ
[音楽]
パッと見だとさすがにわからないと思い
ますこちら
トリックアートですいわゆる3億のお家に
穴が開いてるように見える壁紙をあそこに
貼りました実際の工事かなり大変でした
ご覧くださいどうぞ
[音楽]
[拍手]
最高はいというわけで3億円のお家の壁に
馬鹿でかい穴が開いてるように感じると
思いますあのこれですねずっとやってみ
たくてこれなんか
コンクリートの壁だからさ
ぶち油でそんな感じあるじゃないですか
そして私はじめしゃ撮ってる人間
ぶち破りそうじゃないですかだから全然
こんなことだってでもワンチャンありそう
なのかなと思ってちょっと貼ってみました
トリックアート
めっちゃリアルなんかマジで割れてる
みたいに見えるのこれちょっと近くまで
行ってみましょうこれ庭から見るとさすが
わからないと思うんですけども近くで見る
とねちょっとわかるねさすがに近く来まし
たいやめっちゃでけえよこの穴マジで
なんかさオレンジさこういうなんか
コンクリートの穴みたいなやつがポンポン
ポンってあるもうそこもかなりリアルに
再現させていただきました先生ももう完全
に再現してこの没入感この日々の割れ方と
かね
めっちゃ嫌この感じただ穴を開けるだけ
じゃなくて
穴が開いた結果周りも日々入ってますよっ
ていう感じを完璧に表現しましたこれこう
いうねなんか鉄球みたいなのも出たりして
ます
超リアル
絶対言われてるよこれもう絶対一生懸命
開いたんだろうね
想定される可能性としては
外国からの攻撃とかもありそうですし
アンチによって家に大砲打ち込まれた実験
による内部爆発ロケット突撃とかいろんな
可能性が考えられますけども
まずないと思いますまずないけど私初め
社長ならアリエル今日の動画ははじめしゃ
ちょーの竿くんのお家にバカでかい穴が
ぶち込まれてるドッキリやっていきたいと
思います
管理人は
泣きますそうそうトリックハートなので
角度によってちょっとしたらすぐバレて
しまうかもしれないまだターゲットがバカ
すぎて気づかずにマジであんなが空いてる
んじゃないかと思って悲しむこともあり
得るいろんな可能性が感じられると思うん
ですけどとりあえずターゲットに見せて
いきたいと思いますちなみにこちらお値段
100万円です
[音楽]
今日もイケメンだなぁ
あれ持ってきてもらって裏庭にさあ
ホウ砂あればさから左奥のホース
包丁取ってきたじゃん
[音楽]
蛇口を見てほしいというか分かりました
さああとは気づくかどうかだけで澤部後輩
澤部は割と3向けの家には遊びに来ている
方なので
家の以上には気づきやすいと思います今
ホースの方
じっと見ている何がおかしいのか様子を見
ているところですこの距離感で気づくこと
はかなりかなり気づきやすいと思うんです
けどもとりあえず
後ろ見た後ろ見たうーんと気づかない
ホースこの
距離で気づかないのは相当間抜けなのか
それとも普通こうなのかあ放送を上も見
つつ
放送を見ています
おっとこいつマジでこちらがさらに
本当にマジで
冗談じゃないよさあもう投げるないつ
気付くんだサメ
すごい
わかりづらかったです分かりづらいわけ
ないだろこれ
1回1回
[音楽]
あー
今日もイケメンだね
[音楽]
第一選手今入場しました
真後ろに穴が開いていますあなたの大切に
大切にしていたお家に穴が開いています仮
にいつ気づくのかまずはしっかりの方に
よる
異常がないからさっきサーベが壊した放送
しっかりと見ていますもうほんと純粋に
直していただきたい純粋に直していただき
たいですさあ直せるホースの奥には
しっかりと穴が見えていた
直してくれるのが長野大地ここは放送を
直したい
壊れていますねかなり力を入れて治そうと
していますねマジ
壊れてんのこれいや本当なんですよこれは
完全にサビが悪いですさあこれで水が出れ
ば完全に治るというところですが直して
いただきたい気持ちもありますがどちらか
というと穴に気づいてほしいそう思って
いる初め社長です
水が出ない水が出ないこの距離で気づかな
いって金にこれマジで気づかないんかな
おっとここで
飛んでったホースのパブがさらに壊れて
しまったなんてことしてくれたんだもう
ホースは使い物にならないそして取りに
行くも気づかない中の大地管理人いやこれ
気づかないんかなこの距離でさあまだ
コツコツとなんなら直してほしい
[音楽]
ここで気づいたー
ここで気づいた管理人ただ放送直しては
止めない限りの仕事を最後まで全うして
いる待機でやったぞ中野大地その
点を止めるのはなかったからね
びっくりしたの本当に
作ってるねー
[音楽]
確かにさあ今度は実際に開けます何これ
貼ったの
貼りました
100万円です
お金かかったらそんなかなりこだわって
作らせてもらいました
しばらくこのままで
外から来た
襲撃受けてるみたいな感じになるよ絶対
これ
[音楽]
行くぞ
イケメン
発見しました
イケメン入りますよろしくお願いします
すごいどうも今日もすごいね
えっ
うわぁ
よし行こうけ
裏庭の
シャワーは変だからちょっと見てきて
ほしい裏庭のシャワーがね
シャワーヘッドだけ持ってきてくれたら
助かる
いつも頼むあの奥にあるじゃん
ヘッド
左奥のそれちょっと見てほしい
ですねさあゴリラが今放線に近づく後ろに
は嫌いな穴が開いています今のところ
結構時間かかってるんで意外と気づかない
とかありますね
なんで嬉しそうなんだー
[音楽]
君の名は針の隕石